we can fans expect leading up to the
finances and final up so well and you
know it's interesting I read something
on social media that the other day and
someone wrote it just gets better and
better that's what they wrote episode by
episode I don't see that's what they
wrote over there I just read that and
thought oh it's interesting that the
audience is seeing a development because
we are trying to just present different
cases different topical relevant issues
for people to discuss but I think as
time goes on and there's a natural
organic development that's happening in
the story line within the characters
lives and stuff so even though we do
like the story of the week if you like
other developments are happening and
then around that which means you're
getting more layers each time you're
getting what you enjoyed at the
beginning and then you're getting more
of the characterization as well as
always so hopefully it'll just it will
move in an in an organic way without
forcing or banging people over the head
or anything it's just kind of getting
into it these characters lives a bit
more what no no I haven't seen her but I
would love to yeah and have cancer
survivors or those battling disease
reached out to either one of you to just
discuss some of the topics in the show
have reached out to anyone on the show
just discussing oh yeah I mean people
all the time who come up and say my
sister's dealing with it or my father is
or I was dealing with it or or something
and it's amazing and scary how how how
come and it is how many people are
affected by this disease and dealing
with it and and when people are
appreciate seeing someone on TV who just
just seen someone who is dealing with it
whether you're doing that well or
probably whatever that just that fact
alone is sort of reassuring and that is
really nice to hear because because it
is an enormous disease to to tackle well
the number six in my head actually and
it it's 39.6 last time I checked percent
of people will be diagnosed with cancer
at some point in their lifetime
yeah so it's something that yeah yeah
yeah a little different question but are
you familiar with the show Titan so they
have an incredible obstacle course how
do you think you guys would do can we be
a team can Freema and I team up and do
it okay we would crush it if it was new
together that'd be great yeah on the
show
what's our ship name three Ryan oh I
know our character names me and you
Eggman
I mean honestly man a demon and eggl
they're both just like strange names
with a lot of G's in them so anything
g-g-gee unit g-unit it might be taken by
going on